leang Fu was appointed China's defense
minister in March and had been the face
of its rapidly expanding military
diplomacy but on Tuesday State media
announced his removal by Presidential
decree with no reason given the order
was approved by the national people's
Congress standing committee a top
parliamentary body so far no replacement
has been named Lee hasn't been seen in
public since attending a China Africa
security Forum in Beijing in August he's
the second high-ranking official to be
Ed in recent months in July former
foreign minister chin gun was suddenly
stripped of his title also without
explanation analysts say the shakeups
show how opaque and unpredictable
Chinese leadership has become under
President cin ping there is perhaps more
instability creeping into the operation
of of she's power in Beijing it might
not threaten him but it could certainly
influence
policymaking Lee's dismissal comes days
before Beijing is scheduled to host a
regional security Forum observers will
be watching who will represent China at
that forum and whether leang Fu's
replacement will be able to improve ties
with the Pentagon the US sanctioned Lee
in 2018 for his role in procuring
weapons from Russia it was a major
sticking point for Beijing a new defense
minister may be able to pave the way for
the reopening of military Communications
between the two sides which were SED
last year Katrina Hugh aler aing
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz